as the water level at lake mead  potentially continues to drop in these  drought conditions pumping station 1  would become inoperable at a lake  elevation of 1050 feet  pumping station 2 would become  inoperable at an elevation of 1 thousand  feet  however our third intake tunnel extends  two and a half miles toward the center  of lake mead giving us the ability to  pull drinking water from the deepest  part of the lake  combine that with the power of our low  lake level pumping station and it allows  us to draw water from below 900 feet  ensuring southern nevada has access to  its full share of lake mead  it's below 900 feet where no water can  be released through hoover dam  downstream to users in california  arizona and mexico